hi guys scifi recapped here before we
start warning spoilers ahead
today i'm gonna explain a 2017 japanese
live action fantasy movie called jojo's
bizarre adventure diamond is unbreakable
the movie starts in a room with a serial
killer named angelo who's currently
being chased by the police
not long after the police bust into the
room but the killer has already escaped
on his way to escape the killer meets a
mysterious man who suddenly shoots an
arrow through his neck as the man
recites some words the man congratulates
him
suddenly the killer is resurrected with
the water bursting near him because of
this the police managed to catch him and
then interrogate him angelo answers with
silence as he realizes he can control
water
he then kills the guard and escapes
again now with a strange water creature
that he summoned the scene continues to
a high school student named koichi
preparing to go to school on his way
he's stopped by delinquent students
they forced koichi to give them his
money
suddenly a man named josuke passes by
and bumped into one of the delinquents
the delinquent then insults him saying
that he has stupid hair
josuke becomes angry and surprisingly he
has power and beats them up the
delinquents get hurt badly but strangely
the wounds on them are gone as josuke
leaves
the delinquents then run away scared of
joe's k
turns out this power can't be seen by
others as koichi didn't see josuke's
power
in the park angelo continues his action
he uses the water creature to kill a man
and control the other one
on the way home josuke meets the
controlled man now with a knife holding
someone as hostage the controlled man
then insults him by saying his hair is
stupid josuke becomes angry and uses his
power to punch through the hostages and
his stomach
but then again the wounds are gone and
nothing happened to them the water
creature then shows up and runs away
from the scene josuke is shocked by the
creature and then leaves
because of this angelo makes josuke as
his next target at night the mysterious
man shows up again and shoots an arrow
at a stranger this time the stranger is
not resurrected and then he leaves the
next day koichi meets jotaro and he asks
koichi to bring him to josuke jotaro
then meets josuke and he claims to be
josuke's nephew jotaro told him he will
be getting his father's inheritance but
then josuke rejects the inheritance
jotaro also asks him if he's been seeing
things
sadly josuke ignores him and leaves
jotaro tries to stop him but he
misunderstands and then prepares to
attack him
turns out jotaro also has power he uses
his power to stop the time and counter
josuke's attack he then explains that
this power is called stan's but once
again josuke says he's not interested in
the other stand users and leaves
meanwhile angelo has been following the
mysterious man the mysterious man
invites him to have dinner together
angelo asks the man what he should do
after receiving the power
the mysterious man then replies that he
can do anything he wants thus he
continues to hunt josuke meanwhile
josuke is having dinner with his mother
tomoko and his grandfather yohei who
turns out to be a police officer
yohei talks about how happy he is to be
able to have dinner together every day
the next day jotaro realizes that the
killing done by angelo is always near
water thus he realizes that angelo's
stan uses water as power a few moments
later angelo arrives at josuke's house
the rain pours down and angelo commands
his stand to kill the entire family
inside tomoko asks josuke to have dinner
with her but he refuses
then her mother drinks water before she
goes and suddenly josuke notices
something strange
he immediately uses his power to get the
creature inside his mother
turns out josuke's decision is correct
that the stand is inside his mother and
he manages to trap it into a bottle
josuke informs jotaro that he caught the
stand because of this jotaro is coming
to take the stand
josuke then goes to the bathroom at the
same time yohei comes to take a liquor
but it seems like he can't find the
bottle
seeing this the stand transforms into a
bottle of liquor and then johay takes
the bottle with him when josuke's back
suddenly there's a loud noise coming out
from his grandfather's room he rushes
there but unfortunately his grandfather
is already wounded from the stan's
attack josuke doesn't seem to be
flustered at all as it turns out his
power is that he can restore anything
broken back to normal then they go to
fight angelo's stand the stand boils
himself and becomes steam so he can
enter josuke's body easily they go to
another room to avoid the steam but
unexpectedly the stand already planned
this as the room is filled with mist
from the air purifier the stand starts
to attack josuke from inside but
surprisingly josuke already predicted
this would happen and he brings out the
stand inside rubber gloves then they go
outside to angelo's location turns out
the damage done to the stand also
affects the user as angelo is beaten up
as well
to punish him josuke doesn't bring him
to the police or kill him but josuke
mixes him with a huge stone near them
and traps him forever
he then goes to his grandfather but
strangely his grandfather hasn't woken
up turns out his grandfather is already
dead before the power activates and
jotaro's power can only restore anything
that is broken not to bring back a dead
person back to life
before the funeral tomoko tells a story
about his grandfather
16 years ago his grandfather couldn't
protect a high school girl since then he
blames himself as a failed policeman
never tried to get promotion and
desperately wants to protect the city at
the funeral josuke sees the mysterious
man and decides to follow him koichi
sees this and also goes after josuke
they arrive at a big mansion where the
mysterious man reveals himself as kecho
his brother okuyasu attacks koichi and
somehow kaicho manages to land an arrow
shot to him okuyasu then tries to stop
josuke from healing koichi
left with no choice they engage in a
battle
josuke eventually realizes the stand
okuyasu has that is to erase space with
the right hand
because of this josuke dodges the next
incoming attacks and the attack
backfires to okuyasu after that josuke
finds that koichi is missing and decides
to go inside he meets again with keicho
who claims that koichi isn't chosen
suddenly okuyasu comes back in and kecho
immediately attacks both yosuke and
okuyasu saying that okoyasu isn't needed
anymore kaichou kept attacking until
okoyasu got hurt fatally josuke also
gets hurt and then brings okuyasu to
retreat
josuke asks him for information about
his brother's stand but unfortunately
okuyasu rejects him
surprisingly instead of killing him he
heals all of okuyasu's wounds okuyasu is
confused and asks why yosuke would heal
his wounds
yosuke then answers simply by saying he
had no reason to die yosuke also reveals
that he can't heal his own wounds yosuke
then gets back to the same location
okuyasu also comes and helps to bring
koichi to the hallway josuke then
immediately heals koichi after that
okuyasu leaves
suddenly there's a group of mini
soldiers who come there which turn out
to be keicho's stand
josuke then tries to defend both koichi
and him from the attacks
not long after kaicho comes again now
bringing his entire force
surprisingly koichi can now see the stan
knowing this he forces koichi to show
his stand he then stabs koichi which
makes him panic and accidentally summons
an egg after that he uses all of his
forces to attack them
josuke deflects all the bullets that are
shot at him to finish the attacks kaicho
shoots missiles at joe's k and then he
passes out
seeing this makes koichi angry and he
unconsciously activates his power and
his stand hatches from the egg
unfortunately the stand can't do
anything
joe's case suddenly wakes up and
restores the missiles
after that he shoots the missiles back
at keicho which hits keicho and all of
his forces disappear keicho runs
upstairs and then both jyozke and koichi
chase after him there they met a
monster-like person keicho tells them
that the monster is his father who is
already beyond saving and forgot
everything
he has tried so many ways to kill him
but none of it affects his father the
reason he uses the bow is to get someone
with a stand that has the power to kill
his father jose noticed a box and then
restored it back where the monster found
the old family picture of themselves
turns out the monster still remembers
his family after that josuke offers to
heal his father but kecho must give in
the bow and arrow to him okuyasu then
comes and reconciles with his brother
not long after an anonymous stand user
attacks okuyasu with the stand
but unfortunately koichi shield him from
being attacked
not long after the stand blows up and
after that the bow and the arrow are
gone
at the end of the movie josuke talks to
jotaro saying that he will continue his
grandfather's effort that is to protect
the town okuyasu and koichi also
approach josuke to help him as they go
to school together
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching